In our Japanese curriculum,
we have introduced a system called daily grades
. Before coming to the Japanese class, students should
practice drills and other things online.  So, the bottom line is,
depending on tomorrow's performance.
Well, it's different depending on the instructor, but I think that
by giving
these daily grades,
it will also motivate the students.
It's on the second floor, but we do it twice a semester.The interviewees
are
interviewed for about five to seven minutes
.
The
interview test is usually five to seven minutes
long, but if there are 50 students
, it will be over in one more day, usually in one day.  However,
depending on the grade,
it may take two days.
So, as a feedback, the best score for a student is, for example, 10 points
.
If so, I will personally
tell the student